how do you know how do you test if
something is a function or not now you
can look at the graphs that's what we
did before right how would you know
since I'll do it from here so you can
draw a line like going downwards but
mine's going to go across since every
input has one output and no more okay
you can identify a function with
something that we call the vertical line
test if you have a rule up with you a
ruler I want you to place your ruler
against your graph that you just drawn
and we're going to do the vertical line
test all the vertical line test is you
take a vertical line and you place it
across your relation okay if you can
move it anywhere in your relation which
corresponds to any input then you should
have exactly one output and only one
output maximum right so do you notice
when you put it up against the straight
line when you put it up against the what
else that'll give you the trig function
when you put up against the log curve
your ruler your vertical line when you
test the only LM intersect one you don't
that and then you put it up against the
unit circle and what happens in sex what
if that cell functions going to get more
wipes
how does he know what this will look
like now you've already got what y
equals sine X looks like it waves up and
down up and down up and down right this
is not going to wave up and down it's
going to wave left to right from side to
side so when you put your vertical line
against that what's going to happen it's
going to give us a very nice
an infinite number of times it's not
functional
no here's the thing right you can
identify a function with a vertical line
test you can force any relation you like
you can force a relations should the
color function and this gets to a
question which you guys asked me like
the beginning of the year if or weird a
range prescription I want you to look at
that UNICEF we're to look at the unit
circle
what was its range again make negative
one to one right
we actually say the natural range would
be negative one to one
okay because that's just what occurs you
didn't extra do anything to it that's
just what the unit circle is okay but
you can respect the ledge you can
restrict that range to anything you like
but some of those restrictions will
produce a function
think about it for example bow streak
that what part of the circle do like it
I get the top half right this is a
semicircle not want a circle anymore but
the part of the circle that I've got
passes the vertical line test every
value of x that you put in
you'll only get out one value of y so
that's a function now it's a relation
that we're forced with a range
restriction to have just Y you put one
output every time okay and we have to do
this sometimes for a dozen this guy that
you have been using for years it started
as a relation here's the relation it
started as
okay draw this on with me this one's
important come to the black you'll see
used to drawing parabolas that are
facing up the normal way that this is a
bit of a weird idea he wrecks away slops
so it's sideways it looks like that this
is not a function it's our it's a
relation come here I agree
just a boy run think how will I restrict
this to make it a function I'm going to
do it in much the same way I do this in
fact exactly the same way I'm just going
to erase this part down yup
now it's the function that's the square
root of x that's why the square root of
x is not plus or minus whatever that
value happens to be like of 95 for
instance it's only the top one because
we wanted to be a function not a
relation